tomorrow the 11th of November marks the
100th anniversary of the end of the
First World War President Trump and the
first lady are taking part in Memorial
events in France this weekend meanwhile
across the channel in London a very
public tribute is lighting the night sky
to remember those Britain lost in the
war to end all wars Mark Phillips has
the story
a bugler plays the last post on the
Tower of London wall a flame appears
carried by one of the towers ceremonial
Beefeater Guards one flame becomes two
then three civilian volunteers begin
lighting others first tens then hundreds
then thousands until a river of fire
surrounds the ancient tower a 10,000
lights fill the dry moat a tribute to
the hundreds of thousands who fell in a
war that ended a century ago flames me
represent both the kind of spirits and
the energy of the all of those lost men
but also the hope of peace flickering
flames that represent something else too
says the tributes designer Tom Piper but
also have fragile pieces and how we have
to safeguard our democracy even now the
commemoration has the soundtrack of
powerful poetry that speaks of love and
death written by a long-forgotten
American Mary Borden was a wealthy
Chicago socialite who had moved to
England with their British husband when
the first world war broke out she set up
and worked at a field hospital on the
front lines there meeting a British
officer who would become her second
husband and to whom she wrote the words
that now compliment the flames you would
not falter at the last my friend nor put
to shame your clear courageous mind
under the Menace of the desolate
mirac alex is the sound artist who
discovered mary Borden's poems I'm
totally in awe of this woman I'm so glad
the world has sort of woken up to her a
little bit because too often female
artists seem to vanish from history now
like those she wrote about mary borden
is again part of the history of that
terrible time for CBS this morning
Saturday Mark Phillips London I did not
know about Mary Borden that's
fascinating I know it's sure I love the
idea the it represents the loss of the
men but also the hope for peace you're
truly a beautiful statement